Boris Johnson on his way to open the
first Saturday Sisson of the House of
Commons in nearly 40 years his motorcade
filing into Parliament the public filing
into lined up to witness what they
thought would be a moment in history a
meaningful vote on Boris Johnson's
brexit deal but that meaningful moment
delayed after MPs passed a vote forcing
him to request a delay and the PM
abandoned his vote he'd come to the
chamber that morning hopeful as he
pleaded with MPs to pass his deal now is
the time mr. speaker to get this thing
done and I say to all members they must
come together to end it has come
together as Democrats to end this
debilitating feud things looked like
they were moving his way for exit ears
who'd hated Tories amazed deal decided
they could live with Boris Johnson
some of the Tauri euro files finally
move into his bench to assure him I will
vote for his deal but the DUP shaking
their heads in disbelief this p.m. they
think has sold them down the river it
drives a couch and horses through the
Belfast agreement by altering the cross
community consent mechanism it was once
said that new British Prime Minister
could ever agree to such terms once said
by Boris Johnson please reconsider the
pressure on the Union made quite clear
by the Scottish nationalists here
Scotland has been totally and utterly
shafted Wales what he'd leave Northern
gets to remain in the EU single market
and customs union a special arrangement
to protect its interest and people
Scotland has been ignored labour fearful
that mr. Johnson's brexit deal is just a
No Deal cliff edge postponed this is a
trap door to no deal
the idea that this does not lead to a No
Deal brexit is wrong and nobody should
vote for this deal on the base that it
is the way to ensure that we don't leave
at the end of 2020 on WTO terms on her
feet the one person in the chamber who's
been in Boris Johnson's shoes standing
here I have a distinct sense of deja vu
if you want to deliver a back seat if
you want to keep faith with the British
people if you want this country to move
forward then vote for the deal today may
be more sympathetic now to what his
predecessor enjoyed and she certainly
supportive of him but others support
more qualified this exile conservative
force in a vote requiring the PM to ask
for an extension whether or not his deal
is approved Thank You mr. speaker
the purpose of the amendment as has been
said in several interventions and
speeches is to keep in place the
insurance policy provided by the been
Act which prevents us from crashing out
automatically if there is no deal in
place by the 31st of October that then
put to the vote the eyes to the right
322 the nose to the left
306
mr. net we got his way the government
did not the last the opportunity to have
a meaningful vote has effectively been
passed up because the meaningful vote
has been voided of meaning
he's now required to write a letter to
the EU asking for a brexit extension but
Boris Johnson insists there won't be one
I will not negotiate a delay with the EU
his opponents clear he must the Prime
Minister must now comply with the law he
can no longer use the threat of a No
Deal crash out to blackmail members to
support his sellout deal if he doesn't
comply there'll be consequences
Prime Minister you'll find yourself in
court superstar today has morphed into
scrambling for a plan B Saturday mr.
Johnson wanted this to be his my deal no
delay moment but it hasn't quite worked
out like that
he's now legally required whether he
likes it or not to ask for an extension
from the EU and as for his brexit deal
the vote now postponed 12 days out from
brexit and still no clarity on whether
he can fulfill that do or die pledge the
government says it will press on trying
to get MPs to back a deal before October
the 31st mr. Johnson desperate to avoid
delay this is setback video hope it
doesn't turn into total defeat Beth
Rigby Sky News Westminster